.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Mann) Alles, was ich gelernt habe,
mein theoretisches Rüstzeug,
habe ich in der Schweiz gelernt,
auch die Arbeitsmoral.
Ich bin in der Schweiz aufgewachsen.
(Frau) Viele Menschen
haben mir geholfen
oder mir Dinge beigebracht.
Ich möchte mein Wissen und das,
was ich bekommen habe, weitergeben.
Mariana Linn und Edin Dacic machten
ihre Erfahrungen in der Schweiz.
Sie trugen das erworbene Wissen
nach Bosnien und Rumänien,
wo sie Hunderte von Arbeitsplätze
geschaffen haben.
Ich möchte herausfinden, was hinter
diesem grossen Erfolg steht.
* Gemächliche Musik *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Mein Traum war es immer,
unternehmerisch tätig zu sein.
Nicht Wirtschaft studieren,
aber Unternehmer sein.
Die Firma Daccomet AG, die ich als
22-jähriger Student gegründet habe,
also vor vielen Jahren,
besitzt zwei Fabrikationsstätten:
eine in Bosnien und Herzegowina
und eine in Serbien.
Beide Firmen sind Möbelproduzenten.
In Bosnien sind 400,
in Serbien rund 300 Angestellte.
Beide produzieren Möbel für IKEA.
Edin Dacic kam 1974 als Fünfjähriger
mit seinen Eltern in die Schweiz.
Sein Vater ist Zahnarzt,
er stammt aus Montenegro,
die Mutter war
Sozialwissenschaftlerin aus Serbien.
Er studierte an der Hochschule
St. Gallen Internationale Beziehungen
mit Schwerpunkt Wirtschaft.
Edin ist verheiratet
und hat zwei Kinder im Schulalter.
Mit seiner Firma Daccomet ist
Edin Dacic seit über zwei Jahrzehnten
auf dem Balkan
geschäftlich erfolgreich.
Drei bis vier Tage in der Woche
verbringt er
in seinen Produktionsstätten.
Ich begleite ihn auf einer Reise
zu seiner Möbelfabrik in Bosnien.
Ich bin in den 70er-/80er-Jahren
in der Schweiz aufgewachsen.
Damals war die Schweiz
ein sehr geschlossenes Land.
Es gab noch keine globalisierte
Ökonomie zwischen den Ländern.
Alles war viel enger.
Als mir jemand erklärte,
was es braucht,
um in der Schweiz
Karriere zu machen -
einen Abschluss haben,
im Militär Offizier sein etc.
und mit der Befürchtung zu leben,
dass mir wegen meines Nachnamens
gewisse Positionen
verwehrt blieben -
das war für mich inakzeptabel.
Ich habe hier eine geschäftliche
Möglichkeit gesehen,
mit relativ wenig Kapital
einen hohen Leverage zu erreichen.
Die Fabrik gab es bereits.
Nach der Tragödie der 90er-Jahre
hatte sie einen viel tieferen Wert,
als wenn man sie
nach dem Krieg gekauft hätte
oder wenn man sie jetzt
kaufen würde.
* Entspannte Musik *
Willkommen in Sarajevo.
Die bosnische Hauptstadt Sarajevo
war schon immer
eine kosmopolitische Stadt.
Viele Religionen
leben hier nebeneinander.
In nächster Nähe befinden sich
Kirchen, Synagogen und Moscheen.
Der gnadenlose Krieg
in den 90er-Jahren
zerstörte
das friedliche Zusammenleben.
Heute zieht die
Stadt wieder Touristen an -
aus den Nachbarländern,
aber auch aus Übersee.
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik *
Die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
des Landes kommt nur langsam voran.
Es findet eine Entwicklung statt.
Man kann nicht sagen,
es wurde nicht investiert.
Aber es ist viel zu wenig passiert.
Es fehlt an politischer Stabilität.
Ohne politische Stabilität
kann es keine
wirtschaftliche Stabilität geben.
Und ohne wirtschaftliche Stabilität
fliessen keine oder zu wenig
ausländischen Investitionen.
Ich arbeite
mit der Fabrik Standard AD
schon seit dem Jahr 2000
für Daccomet zusammen.
2004 hat Daccomet
die Mehrheit übernommen.
Zu Beginn waren es 84,5 %.
Mittlerweile sind es 100 %.
Hier in Prnjavor
produziert die Fabrik Standard
auf mehr als 10'000 m2 Möbel.
102 Artikel
werden für IKEA hergestellt,
die weltweit vertrieben werden.
Die Belegschaft
kommt aus den Dörfern der Umgebung.
Der Lohn eines Arbeiters,
rund 400 Euro,
liegt zwar im Durchschnitt
der Branche in Bosnien,
trotzdem ist er um einiges tiefer
als der Lohn eines Arbeiters
in Westeuropa.
* Das Gespräch
wird von Maschinenlärm übertönt. *
Die Firma
war in einem desolaten Zustand.
Die Firma konnte nur überleben,
weil sie während des Krieges
z.B. Särge produziert hat.
Es ging nur ums Überleben.
Der Generaldirektor, der schon
im Sozialisums Generaldirektor war,
hatte mit einer Handvoll Mitarbeiter
dafür gesorgt,
dass die Firma
nicht geplündert wurde.
Das kam oft vor.
Guten Morgen.
Ich möchte die Sitzung
mit der Skype-Konferenz
von letzter Woche beginnen,
weil nicht alle teilgenommen haben.
Deshalb möchte ich Sie bitten,
uns kurz zu sagen,
welche Lieferungen
im Moment anstehen.
Wie sind die Entwicklungen und die
Prognosen für die nächsten Wochen?
Die Arbeitswoche von Edin Dacic
beginnt mit der Sitzung
mit seinen Abteilungsleiterinnen
und Abteilunsgleitern.
Sie berichten ihm über den aktuellen
Stand der Produktion.
Die Auftragsbücher
scheinen zufriedenstellend zu sein,
das Geschäft läuft.
Boro Jevdjenic
ist schon seit über 30 Jahren
Generaldirektor der Fabrik.
Nach dem Krieg stand sie vor dem Aus.
Ohne das Engagement von Edin Dacic
hätte die Fabrik nicht überlebt,
sagt er.
Zu Beginn der Zusammenarbeit
mit Edin Dacic
finanzierte er
nur die Produktion der Ware.
Edin gab den Kredit und zahlte
die Differenz für die Arbeit,
sobald die Ware
über den Fluss Sava ging,
also über die Grenze
ausgeliefert wurde.
Eine Zeit lang
haben wir so produziert.
Und nach der Zollabwicklung
hat er uns bezahlt.
Und so lief das und mit der Zeit
haben wir sein Vertrauen gewonnen,
und es war auf einmal
einiges möglich.
Ich frage Boro Jevdjenic,
was genau Edin Dacic mit seiner Firma
Daccomet hierher gebracht hat?
Investitionskapital
als flüssige Mittel.
Ohne das hätten wir die normale
Produktion gar nicht starten können.
Zweitens: eine gewisse Sicherheit
für die Handlungsfähigkeit
von Standard.
Drittens: Investitionen,
die mit Nachdruck
die Kapazitäten gesteigert haben.
Das sind drei Punkte.
Was ist der vierte?
Er ist und bleibt ein Schweizer.
Damit ist alles gesagt.
Mit ihm ist auch das Vertrauen
des Abnehmers gekommen.
Er hat immer sein Wort gehalten
und stand für jede Abmachung ein.
Und die Produktion
wuchs von Monat zu Monat.
Wir machten grosse Fortschritte.
Wir investierten ca. 10 Mio. Euro.
Wir sind von 65 auf 400 Angestellten
gewachsen.
Wir wachsen weiter.
Am meisten Hoffnung
geben mir aber die Menschen.
Die Firma Standard
hat mir einen Job gegeben,
obwohl ich gerade erst
von der Hochschule kam.
Ich war noch sehr unerfahren.
Aber die Firma
hat in mich investiert,
auch in meine Weiterbildung,
so dass ich der Firma
etwas zurückgeben kann.
Nach weniger als einem Jahr bei uns
leitete sie bereits eine Abteilung.
Mit Ende 20 ist sie schon
ausführende Direktorin.
Wenn ich die Arbeit bei Standard
nicht hätte,
wäre ich heute nicht in Prnjavor.
Mein Job ist der einzige Grund,
warum ich hier
in meinem Heimatort lebe.
Ich wäre sicher wie andere Leute
aus meiner Generation,
die keine Arbeit in ihrem Beruf
gefunden haben,
ins Ausland gegangen.
Vielleicht hätte ich einen Job auf
einem Kreuzfahrtschiff angenommen,
um die Welt zu sehen, Fremdsprachen
zu lernen und um Geld zu verdienen.
Ja, ich bin die einzige Frau
im Topmanagement der Firma.
Ich habe dabei gar keine
schlechten Erfahrungen gemacht.
Ich werde von allen Kollegen
respektiert,
auch, weil mich
der Inhaber der Firma respektiert.
Er respektiert alle gleichermassen,
egal ob Frau oder Mann.
Er sieht alle Menschen gleich und
achtet ihre Aufgaben im Unternehmen.
Standard ist der Arbeitgeber
Nummer 1 in Prnjavor.
400 Leute arbeiten hier
und versorgen ihre Familien
von diesem Einkommen.
Die Leute sind sehr zufrieden
mit ihrem Arbeitgeber.
Zum einen, weil der Eigentümer
ein Schweizer ist.
Das gibt schon eine Sicherheit.
Es lässt die Leute
mit Zuversicht in Zukunft schauen.
Zum anderen ist IKEA, die Nummer 1
auf dem globalen Möbelmarkt,
Hauptabnehmer der Firma.
Das alles gibt den Leuten
ein gutes Gefühl
und einen sicheren Arbeitsplatz.
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Stadt Sibiu in der Region
Siebenbürgen in Rumänien.
Hier wurde Mariana Linn geboren.
Auch ihre Erfolgsgeschichte hat
ihren Anfang in der Schweiz genommen.
Nach dem Zusammenbruch
des sozialistischen Systems
suchte die gelernte Krankenschwester
1995 in München Arbeit.
Dort lernte sie auch
ihren früheren Mann kennen,
mit dem sie sich später
in der Schweiz niederliess.
Mariana bildete sich
zur Betriebswirtschafterin weiter
und arbeitete als Finanzkontrollerin
bei einem grossen Technologiekonzern
im Kanton Bern.
Ich habe in Bern,
im Emmental gewohnt.
Auf dem Land,
genauer in Niederhünigen.
Das Emmental ist eine Region
mit vielen Käsereien.
Allmählich kam mir die Idee ...
... irgendwann eine kleine Käserei
in Rumänien aufzubauen.
So habe ich angefangen,
jedes Wochenende
in verschiedenen Käsereien
zu arbeiten.
Ich ging immer um
ca. 3 oder 4 Uhr morgens zur Arbeit,
einfach um die Prozesse
kennenzulernen
und um zu sehen, ob das etwas wäre.
Dank vielen Käsereibesitzer
bekam ich einen guten Einblick.
Die alleinerziehende Mutter
eines achtjährigen Sohnes
ist Gründerin der Firma Carpalat,
die inzwischen
drei Geschäftszweige betreibt:
eine Molkerei,
eine Konditorei und zehn Cafés.
Mariana beschäftigt rund 75
Angestellte, davon über 80 % Frauen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ich wollte mich erkundigen, wie hoch
die Milchproduktion sein sollte.
Ich besuchte in Zollikofen
einen Kurs,
um Technisches und Wirtschaftliches
über Käsereien lernen zu können.
In der Molkereischule in Zollikofen
wurde Mariana Linn grosse
Hilfsbereitschaft entgegengebracht,
als sie von ihrem Traum einer eigenen
Molkerei in Rumänien erzählte.
Sie freuten sich über mein Projekt.
Sie wollten nicht einmal
das Kursgeld annehmen.
Sie haben mir
viel Material mitgegeben, Bücher,
und mir für die Zukunft
alles Gute gewünscht.
Sie erhielt vom Staatssekretariat
für Wirtschaft SECO einen Kredit,
und mit ihren eigenen Ersparnissen
war das Startkapital gesichert.
Mariana Linn kaufte 2003 hier die
stillgelegte Kolchose mit 3 ha Land,
in der einst bis zu 800 Kühe
gehalten wurden.
Ich brauchte zwei Jahre,
um die Utilitäten zu finden.
Das grösste Problem war das Wasser,
denn die Farm
hatte auch früher kein Wasser.
Das Wasser für die Kühe
kam aus Zisternen.
Überall wurde mir gesagt,
ich würde nie Wasser finden.
Marianas Schwägerin in der Schweiz
hatte im Fernsehen
von einem Experten gehört,
der überall, auch in der Wüste,
Wasser findet.
Voller Hoffnung kontaktierte sie
den Mann aus dem Wallis.
Ich erinnere mich, wie ich ihm auf
der Autobahn das Video gezeigt habe.
Er sagte: "Da kann man bohren!
Es gibt schon Wasser."
"Es gibt Wasser auf diesem Land."
Ich habe ihn schief angeguckt:
"Nein, das kann nicht sein."
Eine Bohrung
kostet pro Meter 100 Euro.
Ich kann ich mir nicht leisten,
blind zu bohren.
Dann fragte ich ihn,
ob es möglich wäre,
dass er nach Rumänien kommt.
Er sagte: "Ich komme nach Rumänien,
und wenn wir nichts finden,
bezahlen Sie mir nichts."
Wir bohrten,
und nach zwei Tagen sagte er,
wir sollen die Maschine rausnehmen,
das Wasser werde kommen.
Alle anderen haben schief geguckt:
"Das ist nicht wahr."
Wir haben die Röhre rausgenommen,
und das Wasser kam.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ich wollte ein grosses Projekt
mit einer grossen Molkerei machen.
Gott sei Dank hatte ich
die Unterstützung des SECO.
Ich wurde von ihnen beraten.
Sie haben mir empfohlen,
klein anzufangen,
die Gebäude, die schon stehen,
zu renovieren
und mit weniger Kosten etwas
aufzubauen und das Geschäft starten.
Im Oktober 2005
ist der erste Liter Milch geflossen.
Dann kamen auch die Probleme.
Der Rohstoff war sehr schwierig.
Die Leute haben nicht verstanden,
dass die Qualität gut sein musste.
Wir haben zuerst die Milch
nach Fettgehalt bezahlt.
Es gab aber immer wieder Probleme,
da wir fremde Fette gefunden haben.
Es hatte Schweineschmalz ...
... oder Hühnerfett drin.
Und immer wieder Ähnliches.
Das machte unsere Ware kaputt.
Mariana Linn
liess sich von den vielen Problemen,
die sich ihr in den Weg stellten,
nicht beirren.
Einige Male
konnte sie für deren Lösung
auf ihre Kontakte in der Schweiz
zurückgreifen.
Ich hatte Produktionsprobleme,
die ich nicht lösen konnte.
Ich habe aus der Schweiz
einen supertollen Berater bekommen:
Willy Hugelshofer.
Er ist nach Rumänien gekommen.
Das war ein wichtiger Schritt
und der Schritt,
der uns nach vorne gebracht hat.
Mariana hatte Probleme
mit den Maschinen.
Auch mit der Energie.
Sie hatten immer wieder
Wasser- und Stromausfälle.
Und sie hatte Probleme
mit den Bauern,
die versucht haben,
ihre Milch mit Wasser oder Fett
oder anderen Zutaten zu strecken.
Wir haben daraufhin u.a. eingeführt,
dass sie den Fettgehalt in der Milch
selber messen konnte.
Das wurde im Labor eingeführt,
und wir haben es den Leuten gezeigt.
Mariana hatte somit
ein Mittel in der Hand,
um gegen die Bauern vorzugehen.
Es ist für mich selbst
etwas Schönes, diese Erfahrungen,
die man in einem langen Berufsleben
gemacht hat, sinnvoll weiterzugeben.
Willy hat unsere Prozesse
noch einmal kontrolliert
und richtiggestellt,
bei den Geräten viel rumgebastelt,
auch bei der Temperatur.
So haben wir
alles in den Griff bekommen.
In zwei Wochen hatten wir
ganz neue Qualitätsprodukte.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ich war beeindruckt,
wie sie diesen Betrieb aufgebaut
und geführt hat.
Trotz aller Probleme
ist es immer weitergegangen.
Sie ist willensstark
und trotz allem menschlich.
Interessant ist - das habe ich
erst später in Rumänien erfahren -
dass Mariana in der Schweiz
hier hinten in Niederhünigen
in diesem Dorf gewohnt hat.
Mariana Linn
geniesst die Nähe zur Belegschaft.
Es macht sie stolz, zu sehen,
dass Frauen in ihrem eigenen Dorf
in einem modernen Betrieb
mit fairen Arbeitsbedingungen
beschäftigt sind.
Dennoch
hat sie die Anfangsschwierigkeiten,
mit denen sie als junge Unternehmerin
zu kämpfen hatte, nicht vergessen,
in einem Land,
in dem Korruption und Amtsmissbrauch
noch immer zum Alltag gehören.
Vor 16 Jahren
war ich noch viel jünger. Eine Frau.
Ich erinnere mich, wie ich mit
meinen Plänen zum Veterinäramt ging.
Der Direktor, sehr gross,
stand so vor mir und frage mich:
"Was willst du?"
"Wenn du mit einem
so grossen Stapel Papier kommst,
können wir reden."
Das werde ich nie vergessen.
Der Anfang war wirklich hart.
Aber seitdem unsere Geschäfte
stabil sind,
ist es nicht mehr so.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Auch Edin Dacic holte sich
Unterstützung aus der Schweiz,
als es darum ging, die Produktivität
seiner Fabrik zu steigern
und somit auch konkurrenzfähig
zu werden.
Der grösste Wendepunkt war,
als wir einen Berater
der Swisscontact beantragt haben.
Sie haben sog. Senior Expert Corps,
das sind pensionierte Experten.
Ich stellte einen Antrag
und nach weniger als 48 Std.
haben sie jemanden mit
dem entsprechenden Profil gefunden.
Der Experte Peter Furimann
war Anfang 2005 bei uns
und fragte mich:
"Was willst du von mir?"
"Hier wird ja produziert,
ihr habt die grösste Firma der Welt
als Partner. Was soll ich tun?"
Ich sagte: "Du sollst vergessen,
dass du in Bosnien bist."
"Stell dir vor,
das alles steht in der Schweiz."
Nach drei Monaten hier,
nachdem er sich alles angeschaut
und analysiert hatte,
sagte er: "In der Schweiz
würde man das Doppelte herstellen."
Das umzusetzen
war der nächste Schritt.
Die Belegschaft
glaubte jedoch Edin Dacic nicht,
dass der Arbeitgeber für die
angestrebte Produktionssteigerung
auch den versprochenen doppelten Lohn
auszahlt.
Ich spürte,
dass das Vertrauen fehlte.
Ich schlug einen Deal vor:
"Zwei Monate,
ihr stellt das doppelte her."
"Wenn wir euch
nicht das Doppelte bezahlen,
wisst ihr, dass ich gelogen habe,
und müsst mir nie mehr glauben."
"Dann kehren wir
zu den alten Löhnen zurück."
Nach weniger als zwei Monaten
hatten wir mehr als das Doppelte
hergestellt.
Bist du es, Edin?
- Ja, ich bin's.
Nach der Stimme schon. Tschau, Edin.
- Hoi, hoi.
Es ist schön, dich wieder einmal
zu hören und zu sehen.
Ja.
- Ich habe ein Geschenk mitgebracht.
Ich habe ein grosses Handicap.
Ich weiss nicht, ob du das weisst.
Ich sehe praktisch gar nichts mehr.
Wir haben uns zuletzt
an der Jahresversammlung
von Swisscontact gesehen.
Du hast erzählt, dass die Operation
nicht gut verlief.
Ja, und ich hatte noch einen Unfall.
Ein Auge ist kaputtgegangen.
Ich überbringe dir von allen
aus Bosnien die allerbesten Grüsse.
V.a. von Boro.
- Beste Grüsse zurück.
Er weiss, dass ich heute hier bin.
Damals waren v.a.a die allgemeine
Fabrikationstechniken nützlich.
Und was ganz wichtig war:
die Arbeitszeit-Studie.
Die Arbeitszeit-Studie hat geholfen,
weil jeder Arbeitsplatz
oder jede Arbeit
auf die Wirksamkeit
untersucht wurde.
Es geht nicht darum,
schneller zu arbeiten,
sondern wirkungsvoller.
Das andere war,
dass Herr Dacic, Edin -
wir sind ja per Du -
mir sehr viel Freiraum gelassen hat.
Ich hatte dort
eine Stellung und Möglichkeiten,
die nicht selbstverständlich waren.
Ich konnte sehr viel bewirken
und hatte viel Freiraum.
Auf Berndeutsch gesagt:
Ich konnte überall reinreden,
wo ich es für nötig hielt.
Als ich
nach Ex-Jugoslawien gekommen bin,
sah ich ganz viele Arbeiter,
die z.B. keine Ahnung von
einer technischen Zeichnung hatten.
Sie konnten
keine Handskizzen machen,
mit der man irgendwie
hätte arbeiten können.
Nicht weil sie dümmer
oder weniger intelligent sind,
im Gegensatz zu uns
fehlte ihnen diese Ausbildung.
Edin Dacic stellte früh fest,
dass für mittlere und höhere Kader
im Land
qualifizierte Fachleute fehlen.
Diesem Mangel an Fachkräften wollte
er mit einer Idee entgegenwirken,
die sich bewährt hat.
In den 90er-Jahren
ist das Bildungssystem implodiert.
Die Leute haben die Ausbildung
nicht abgeschlossen
oder der sie war
nicht mehr dieselbe.
Die Schweiz hat so viel Wissen,
das sie gerne teilen würde.
Das muss man nutzen.
So habe ich Leute identifiziert,
die förderungswürdig sind.
In ein paar Jahren könnten sie
höhere Positionen einnehmen.
Durch meine früheren Kontakte
kannte ich Kurt Wüthrich
von der Fachhochschule Biel.
Ich habe ihm das erzählt.
Er sagte: "Wir können alles bieten.
Sagt einfach, was ihr braucht."
If you have enough power
to put this together, I can lift ...
Im darauffolgenden Jahr
wurde an der Fachhochschule für Holz
und Architektur in Biel
ein einjähriger Lehrgang entwickelt,
massgeschneidert für das mittlere
Kader der Holzwirtschaft in Bosnien.
Das modular aufgebaute Training
findet teils Bosnien
und teils hier in Biel statt.
Mitfinanziert wird das Projekt
von der DEZA,
der Direktion
für Entwicklung und Zusammenarbeit.
Wir haben insgesamt
etwa 60 mittlere Kader
aus der Holzwirtschaft
in Bosnien ausgebildet.
Diese Leute
sind zentral in den Betrieben,
weil sie diesen Link
zwischen Produktion
und Topmanagement machen können.
Oft ist es ein grosses Problem,
weil es keine Fachhochschulen gibt,
die diesen Praxisbezug
vermitteln können.
D.h., es gibt eine Lücke,
die wir mit diesem Projekt
zu schliessen versuchen.
Wir werden ein Experiment machen.
Eine Tür
wird von der Sonne angestrahlt.
Das ist unsere Tür -
ein normales Türblatt.
Dahinter haben wir Infrarotlampen,
die für die Sonne stehen.
Diese Lampen sind ziemlich stark.
Sie werden Hitze auf der Oberfläche
der Tür erzeugen.
Wir werden uns anschauen,
wie stark sie sich verbiegt.
Wir werden die Sonne für
eine halbe Stunde scheinen lassen.
Aber, damit es spannend bleibt,
habt ihr nun die Aufgabe,
zu schätzen,
wie stark die Verbiegung sein wird.
Jeder von euch
gibt eine Schätzung ab
und schreibt seinen Namen hier hin.
Es ist der Wunsch
der Direktion der Schule,
dass wir solche Projekte machen mit
Schwellen- und Entwicklungsländern.
Wir haben in Biel die Infrastruktur
mit dem Labor,
den Maschinen, dem Prüflabor.
Wir können viele Arten von Tests
mit Holz und Produkten machen.
Jetzt beginnt die Sonne zu scheinen.
Ihr merkt,
die sind ganz schön heiss.
Also lassen wir sie ein wenig
scheinen und gehen da rüber.
Wir haben sehr viele praktische
Beispiele aus den Betrieben,
die wir in den Vorlesungen
und Kursen benutzen können.
Es ist ein grosser Mehrwert für sie,
wenn sie in die Schweiz kommen.
Jetzt ist es an der Zeit zu messen,
wie stark die Biegung ist.
Genau so,
wie ihr es vorhin gemacht habt.
3,88.
Zeig mal, ob du noch rechnen kannst.
Jetzt schauen wir auf die Liste.
Wer ist am nächsten?
(Frau) Ahmet, 3!
Oh!
Gute Schweizer Schokolade.
Und wer ist der Zweite?
Welche drei Dinge
haben euch am meisten beeindruckt?
Die Firmenbesuche.
Dort haben sie uns gezeigt,
wie sie arbeiten und testen.
Das können wir in der Schule
nicht lernen.
Bei uns überwiegt die Theorie,
hier ist auch der Praxisanteil hoch.
Die Dozenten
sind zugänglicher und offener.
Der Abstand zwischen Dozierenden
und Studierenden ist hier geringer.
Die Schweizer entwickeln
Praxis und Theorie parallel weiter.
Sie reagieren auf Marktbedürfnisse.
Es ist faszinierend,
es ist alles softwarebasiert.
Sie haben an jeder Maschine
einen Barcode-Leser.
Dieser Wissenstransfer
ist sehr wichtig und spannend,
weil wir in der Schweiz
so innovativ sind.
Wir können sehr viel Know-how
transferieren in Länder,
in denen die Menschen keinen Zugang
zu diesem Know-how haben.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Mariana Linn
setzte in ihrem Unternehmen
schon früh auf Nachhaltigkeit.
Die Kunden schätzen die Qualität
ihrer Produkte, in einer Zeit,
in der überall
Billigware angeboten wird.
Sie konnte ihre Produkte in den
Warenhäuser nicht so präsentieren,
wie sie es wollte,
was sie schliesslich motiviert hat,
eigene Verkaufsgeschäfte zu eröffnen.
Ich habe selber
im Geschäft verkauft.
Wir konnten fast jährlich
ein neues Geschäft eröffnen.
Mit dem ersten Geschäft lernten uns
die Kunden besser kennen.
Wir haben als Kunden fast alle
Kindergärten aus der Stadt,
die Krankenhäuser und Altersheime.
Mich freut, dass viele Kinderärzte
unsere Produkte empfehlen.
Wir haben nur weisse Produkte,
keine Zusätze, keine Früchte.
Wir machen nichts rein.
Unsere Zielgruppen sind schon
ernährungsbewusste Menschen.
Als ich in der Schweiz gelebt habe,
reisten wir oft nach Italien.
Es waren die Cafés in Italien,
die es mir angetan haben.
Ich dachte immer, es wäre schön,
ein eigenes Café zu haben.
Das war zwar weit weg,
aber ein Gedanke,
den ich immer im Hinterkopf hatte.
Nun haben wir einige Cafés in Sibiu.
Auch einem weiteren wichtigen
Standbein des Unternehmens,
der Confiserie, liegt eine Erfahrung
aus dem Ausland zugrunde.
Ich habe mir immer gewünscht,
in meiner Stadt
einen guten Kuchen zu essen.
Ich sprach mit meiner Schwester,
die damals in Deutschland war.
Ich fragte sie, ob sie nicht
lernen möchte, wie man Kuchen macht.
Sie solle aber das Gleiche machen,
wie ich es
für die Milchprodukte mache.
So könnten wir
ein Geschäft entwickeln.
So kam sie 2010 nach Sibiu.
Und wir haben
eine kleine Confiserie eröffnet
und mit der Produktion
von Torten und Kuchen angefangen.
Buna dimineata.
- (Alle) Buna dimineata.
* Sie sprechen rumänisch. *
Inzwischen ist die Confiserie
gut gediehen
und zu einer bekannten Adresse
in Sibiu geworden.
Es ist sehr wichtig,
das wirtschaftlich im Griff haben,
damit wir keine Verluste
bei den Rohstoffen haben
und dass wir
die Produktionskosten sehen.
Unser Buchhaltungssystem
habe ich so aufgebaut,
dass man in jedem Moment weiss,
wo ein Kaffee verkauft wurde.
Die Bestände
werden automatisch angepasst.
Und es stimmt alles.
Ich wollte selbstständig arbeiten
und ich wollte das
in meinem Land machen.
Ich habe in der Schweiz
sehr viel gelernt.
Ich wollte etwas
mit den Händen machen, produzieren.
Ich mache das gerne: in der Molkerei
arbeiten, in der Confiserie.
Ich helfe auch gerne
in den Geschäften aus.
Unser Motto ist:
plin de bunătate, nu pe jumătate.
Das heisst auf Deutsch: voll
dabei sein, nicht nur zur Hälfte.
Gut ausgebildetes Personal zu finden,
ist im jungen EU-Land Rumänien
nicht einfach,
weil die Leute lieber
im Ausland arbeiten wollen,
wo sie besser verdienen.
Auch Mariana klagt über die grosse
Fluktuation in ihrem Unternehmen.
Wir finden schon Arbeiter.
Wir nehmen sie auch ohne Erfahrung,
sie werden angelernt.
Dann finden sie in England oder
Deutschland Arbeit und wandern aus.
Wir können nicht mit einem deutschen
oder Schweizer Gehalt mithalten.
Obwohl unsere Bezahlung
für unsere Mitarbeiter
überdurchschnittlich ist.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Dass dynamische, junge Leute
das Land verlassen,
ist ein Problem der ganzen Region.
Bosnien ist seit Jahrzehnten
ein Auswanderungsland.
Fast jeder Dritter Bosnier
lebt im Ausland
und schickt regelmässig Geld
zu Familie in die Heimat.
Dort wird dieses Geld
oft in Immobilien
oder in Lebenskosten investiert.
Somit dient es zwar
dem individuellen Haushalt,
aber nicht der nachhaltigen
Entwicklung des Landes.
Der erste Grund
ist die finanzielle Situation.
Die Leute finden hier keinen Job,
der ihre Existenz sichert.
Der zweite Grund ist,
dass sie in Bosnien keine
sichere Zukunft für sich sehen.
Deshalb wollen sie auswandern, um
in anderen Ländern Arbeit zu finden.
Es ist traurig für ein Land,
wenn die jungen Leute weggehen.
Denn das Land hat in sie investiert
und sie ausgebildet.
Sie gingen hier zur Schule,
zur Universität.
Aber wenn die Zeit kommt
und sie etwas zurückgeben könnten,
indem sie hier arbeiten und dem Land
nützlich sind, gehen sie weg.
Das ist für das Land
eine Katastrophe.
* Hoffnungsvolle Gitarrenklänge *
Es herrscht Perspektivlosigkeit.
Das ist die grössere Gefahr,
weil gute Leute das Land verlassen.
Es gibt viele Gegensätze,
aber einen riesigen Gegensatz
zwischen der Region des Balkans
und der Schweiz, Deutschland,
und den entwickelten
westeuropäischen Ländern:
In der Schweiz
herrscht das Primat der Wirtschaft.
In den Ländern, in denen ich
unterwegs bin, ist es das Gegenteil.
Wir in der Wirtschaft sind dazu da,
um der Politik zu dienen.
Das ist ein Verhängnis,
das sich ändern muss.
Solange sich das nicht ändert,
wird keines dieser Länder
sein volles wirtschaftliches
Potenzial ausschöpfen können.
Der Unternehmer Edin Dacic
nutzt seine einflussreiche Position,
um sich in die Politik des Landes
einzumischen.
Er ist in wichtigen
Unternehmensverbänden aktiv,
tritt viel auf,
und seine Meinung ist gefragt.
Ich begleite ihn zu einem Treffen
von Wirtschaftsleuten
mit Regierungsvertretern
in der Residenz
der Schweizer Botschaft in Sarajevo.
* Stimmengewirr *
Grüezi und herzlich willkommen
zum Swiss Business Lunch.
* Sie spricht englisch. *
Die Absicht
hinter diesen Versammlungen ist,
mit euch in Kontakt zu bleiben,
aber auch laufende Themen
zu besprechen,
die für unsere Schweizer Investoren
in Bosnien und Herzegowina
von Belang sind.
Und um das Networking unter euch
zu fördern.
Edin Dacic spricht offen aus,
was er im Land bemängelt.
An diesem Treffen
gerät er mit Regierungsvertretern
in eine heisse Diskussion
über die zu hohen Staatsausgaben.
Sie müssen verstehen, dass wir
aufgrund der Situation in Bosnien
keine Steuerausfälle
in Kauf nehmen können.
Dadurch würde das Staatsbudget
leiden.
Wir hoffen,
dass die katastrophale Diskrepanz
zwischen dem öffentlichen und
dem Privatsektor aufgehoben wird.
Ich bin nicht einverstanden.
- Lassen Sie mich ausreden.
Wenn wir
über die Löhne im sprechen ...
Ich glaube, in der Föderation
ist es fast das Doppelte.
Lassen sie mich noch etwas anfügen.
Können Sie ein anderes Land nennen,
in dem 60-70 %
des Bruttosozialprodukts
für Staatsverwaltung
verwendet werden?
Nur ein Land?
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Der Staat ist viel zu teuer und gibt
der Gesellschaft zu wenig zurück.
Die Folge davon ist im Endeffekt -
das ist eine lange Kette -,
dass die Nettolöhne der Angestellten
im privaten Sektor zu niedrig sind.
Ich bin sehr gerne dort, weil mir
die Menschen sympathisch sind.
Aber ich habe
sehr viel Antipathie dafür,
dass Reformen
nicht schneller umgesetzt werden,
nicht mehr
in die Wirtschaftsförderung geht.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
* Telefon-Freizeichen *
(Bub) Hallo, Papi.
- Mein Schatz, wie geht es dir?
Gut.
- Was machst du?
Ich spiele mit dem Helikopter.
Helikopter? Ist es dein Helikopter?
Nein, er gehört Naila.
Papa!
Weisst du,
welches Buch ich gerade lese?
Nein, was liest du denn?
Ich komme gleich zurück.
Ja, bring das Buch.
Was steht da? "Das beste
Fussballspiel aller Zeiten."
Super.
Gib mir mal kurz Mama.
Ja.
- Okay.
Hallo.
- Hallo, hallo. Geht's dir gut?
Ja, es ist alles gut.
Wir waren beim Reiten.
Jetzt sind wir da.
Morgen ist der letzte Tag,
dann gehen wir nach Bern.
Am Freitag ist Teacher Conference.
Wann kommst du?
Am Freitagnachmittag.
- Möchtest du auch was sagen?
Tschüss, Papa.
Cao, duša. Ljubav i tatina.
Mich schmerzt es jedes Mal,
wenn ich gehen muss.
Aber umso grösser ist die Freude,
wenn ich zurückkomme.
Das ist der Preis, den man
für diesen Job bezahlen muss.
Ich werde emotional,
wenn es um die Familie geht,
um Kinder.
Wenn es um Ungerechtigkeit geht.
Wenn ich das Gefühl habe,
man will mir geschäftlich
einen Bären aufbinden.
Dann kann ich sehr emotional werden.
Dann brauche ich viel Energie, um
meine Emotionen im Zaum zu halten.
Hallo.
Fahren Sie zur Messe?
- Ja, ganz genau.
Edin Dacic
ist bekannt als guter Netzwerker.
Sein Wirken ist breit und sichtbar.
So ist er z.B.
im Verein i-dijaspora aktiv,
der sich von der Schweiz aus
für die Entwicklung
in Bosnien und Herzegowina einsetzt.
Auf seine Initiative hin
war Bosnien im Jahr 2018
Gastland einer grossen Tourismusmesse
in der Schweiz.
Er ist überzeugt, dass sein Wissen
und seine Verbindungen
auch andere Türen öffnen können.
Ich geniesse es, anderen mit
meinen Erfahrungen helfen zu können.
Da ist sicher
etwas Idealismus dabei.
Ich lerne sehr viel dabei.
Oft ist es so,
dass man bei gewissen Dingen,
die man immer macht,
betriebsblind wird.
Für mich ist es wie Erholung,
etwas anderes zu machen,
wenn es mit Wirtschaft zu tun hat,
z.B. in einer anderen Branche.
Ich geniesse das sehr
und lerne immer wieder dazu,
das ich wieder für meine
eigenen Projekte nutzen kann.
(Bub) Papa?
Ich will nicht lange fahren.
- Nur noch ein bisschen.
Wir sind bald da. Nur noch 3 Min.
Okay?
Das ist aber lang.
- Nein, nicht mehr so lang.
Du kannst anfangen zu zählen,
dann geht die Zeit ganz schnell.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf,
sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn,
elf, zwölf,
13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
21, 22, 23 ...
Seine Kindheit und Jugend verbrachte
Edin Dacic hier in Kreuzlingen.
Eine Zeit,
in der ihn die Identitätsfrage
allerdings sehr stark beschäftigte.
Ich wurde von meinen Eltern
im Geiste erzogen worden,
dass Jugoslawien meine Heimat ist.
Dass wir nur für ein paar Jahre
in die Schweiz gekommen sind
und dass dies
nur eine kurze Episode ist.
Edin ist ein aufmerksamer Sohn.
Es ist egal, wohin er
geschäftlich oder privat geht.
Wenn er ankommt,
schickt er mir immer eine SMS.
So weiss ich immer,
wo er ist und wie es ihm geht.
Das beruhigt mich.
Er war sehr ambitioniert,
ein super Schüler.
Er war sehr sportlich.
Und er war ein guter Sohn.
Jetzt als Geschäftsmann
hat er sich sehr gut bewiesen.
Ich bin wirklich stolz.
Ich bin so froh,
dass er zwei goldige Kinder hat.
Aus dem vorübergehenden Aufenthalt
in der Schweiz
sind inzwischen 45 Jahre geworden.
Edins Mutter
starb vor 13 Jahren an Krebs.
Sein Vater lebt mit seiner
neuen Partnerin Christina zusammen,
die auch in der Zahnarztpraxis
mitarbeitet.
Meine nationale Identität kann ich
nicht geografisch lokalisieren.
Diese Frage
beschäftigte mich früher extrem,
bis ich ca. 19- oder 20-jährig war,
während der Schulzeit.
Mit dem Auseinanderfallen
von Jugoslawien
hat sich mir diese Frage
nie mehr gestellt.
Ich wurde mir bewusst,
dass ich mir meine eigene Identität
schaffen muss.
Ich darf sie nicht
an irgendwelchen Ländern, Staaten,
Nationen oder Religionen festmachen.
Ich denke nicht in solchen Kriterien
oder Kategorien.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ich wusste, dass es laufen wird.
Ich habe für alle Probleme immer
und immer wieder Lösungen gesucht.
Ich lasse mich nicht unterdrücken.
Wenn ich etwas will,
bekomme ich es auch.
Aber ich habe auch viel
dafür gearbeitet.
Nach 16 Jahren kann ich sagen:
Die Leute nehmen mich ernst.
Die Leute aus dem Geschäftsumfeld
kennen mich.
Ich bin korrekt
und ich halte mein Wort.
Ein Mann, ein Wort.
Eine Frau, ein Wort.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Schön, dass ihr alle da seid.
Die ganze Familie ist da:
Göttis, Gotten von Louis, um
seinen vierten Geburtstag zu feiern.
Geniesst den Tag.
Ich bin immer froh,
wenn ich in die Schweiz zurückkomme.
In ein funktionales System,
um meine Batterien aufzuladen.
Für mich ist es die Schweiz
aus naheliegenden Gründen.
Meine Freunde und meine Familie
sind da.
Das gibt mir genug Energie,
um weiterzumachen.
(Alle) # Happy birthday to you.
# Happy birthday to you.
# Happy birthday, lieber Louis,
happy birthday to you.
Ausblasen!
* Jubel *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Sabine Näpflin - 2020